josée legault michèle dawe et d'hélène
budget si bonsoir bonsoir ça
meurtre du petit thomas trudel 16 1
dimanche soir ça a continué je dis ça
compte il lui s'applique quand même un
certain temps afin que les réactions
politiques n'arrivent la mairesse est
allé en fin d'après midi on a vu on a
commencé l'émission avec ça
et elle parle des armes à feu je vais
vous voulez faire en temps et je vous
entendent ensuite a dit oui pour rapport
avec les soit tout seul à montréal
qualification des armes à feu qui
circulent chez les jeunes
bien sûr il ya montréal nous sommes la
métropole mais également d'autres villes
également où il y avait une
recrudescence d'incidents avec des armes
à feu mais évidemment on va on va se le
dire hier demeure pas moins que c'est le
gouvernement fédéral qui a la
responsabilité entière la capacité de
dire les armes chez nous les en deux
points c'est non c'est interdit
d'augmenter les allées peine pour
possession d'armes beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent être faits pour dissuader
des jeunes des jeunes de 16 ans de se
retrouver avec une arme de les commander
par internet ou ou autre chose
alors hélène elles remettent
l'impression jérôme impasse avait déjà
été dit mais compte tenu du drame elle
remet de la pression sur ottawa
oui en même temps la promesse libérale a
changé dans le temps on se rappelle
qu'au départ il voulait remettre dans le
le cas des villes la responsabilité de
bannir ou pas ces armes de poing en
campagne électorale les libéraux ont
changé tant ils ont dit qu'ils
pourraient donner cette responsabilité à
l'échelle provinciale donc les promesses
pourraient décidé de bannir les armes de
poing surtout leur territoire donc ça
faciliterait les choses et libéraux ont
même promis un milliard de dollars pour
faire ça pourrait aider les provinces
les accompagner dans cette interdiction
bon maintenant est ce que ce sera fait
on déjà vu des promesses électorales
libérales en matière de contrôle des
armes à feu qui n'ont pas été réalisés
mais clairement les libéraux ont
progressé dans leurs pensées à cet égard
et ils ont bien vu la queue à l'est de
la municipalité ça ne pouvait pas
fonctionner michel peut pas régler tout
seul
bien entendu mais vous savez le problème
des armes à feu l'on parle des hommes de
points mais les hommes d'affaires en
général c'est une patate chaude qu avec
laquelle les politiciens jongle depuis
toujours depuis le surtout depuis le
drame de polytechnique
parce que ils ont parc en allant trop
loin il ya un prix politique à payer et
on l'a vu au cours de la dernière année
en particulier en campagne électorale
c'est un espèce de jeu d'évasion là
presque qui en ferait le moins possible
pourquoi ils farouche et une certaine
catégorie d'électeurs hélène life
dimension d'abord c'est trudeau voulait
confier ses ovules c'est dingue ça n'a
pas de bon sens peut pas avoir une
politique différente pour chaque ville
parce que les provinces c'est déjà mieux
passer des ensembles plus grand mais il
reste que les frontières internationales
la contrebande à tahoua qui peut
s'occuper de ça les français
interprovincial ces rançons sont théorie
on peut très bien acheter une arme à
tahoua puis traverser au québec et vice
versa alors il est clair que
normal mandat ça devrait être ottawa qui
s'occupe de ça se reproduit que les
villes les corps policiers des villes
des provinces seront pas aussi à contre
a collaboré ils ont une politique plus
globale mais c'est ottawa qui doit les
tables y changer oui bombay le trafic
d'armes à feu à montréal et ailleurs la
sède sa date de plusieurs décennies
donc on arrive quand même très tard dans
la joute si je puis dire là bon oui ce
serait ça devrait une initiative
fédérale par canadienne c'est évident
mais je voudrais pas non plus qu'on
réduise la situation qu'on vit à
montréal assure ça c'est un problème
important
mais le vrai problème c'est la violence
le vrai problème est parce que c'est une
violence qui est parfois par arme à feu
parfois par arme blanche aussi on voit
de plus en plus à l'est des couteaux et
un des trois jeunes d'ailleurs on était
super par continent l'état les derniers
qui ont été qui ont été tués dans des
lycées minassian et dans des quartiers
qui sont délaissés dans des quartiers où
il ya des problèmes sociaux importants
alors oui on peut sortir de notre
chapeau un élément comme le fait valérie
plate et dire bon ben voilà on règle ça
puis on reste tout le reste on sait très
bien que c'est pas vrai on sait très
bien que eu du laisser aller ou si sur
le plan social sur le plan économique et
cetera moi je viens de saint-michel et
gg je comprends comment cette c'est
devenu une marmite et j'ai pas vu des
politiciens sans menez quand c'est un
tas de le faire de manière productive et
constructive j'espère qu'ils vont le
faire mais vous permettrez doute ouais
on a l'impression peut être que cette
fois ci
thomas tout comme ça valait le cas dans
le jeune qui avait été tué desroches
lors de l'explosion de la jeep dans la
guerre des motards impressionnante quand
on vers anvers comme vous dites
je veux aller tout de suite aussi à
celle des enquêtes de la coronaire
est la question qu elle pose c'est la
question qu'on a en tête depuis le début
de cette crise quand on a préparé les
hôpitaux ont une citation du docteur
arruda qui a été interrogé dans le cadre
de cette enquête de l'ats corner sur ce
qui s'est passé dans les sièges celle
des docteur arruda qui répond il y avait
une pensée comme quoi ces milieux là
allaient être touchées mais dans les
faits il ya peut-être eu certes un enjeu
dit il avec la gestion des milieux de
soins qui a induit un être là autrement
dit
est-ce que cette enquête de madame kamel
d'abord va nous apprendre des choses
parce que josé genre comment savez-vous
tour de table ce encore la question qui
reste en suspens on a bien préparé les
hôpitaux pendant l'impression que ces
dix bombes advienne que pourra dans les
sachets seulement
c'est la boîte de pandore et la
coronelle la coronaire kamel est entré
de l'ouvrir la protectrice du citoyen
avait ouvert une partie est serrée à 20
dans les derniers mois mais j'ai
l'impression
parce qu'on a appris à la connaître
évidemment les dossiers de tous ces
chats point que elle ne laissera pas
aller ce dossier là de manière
facile c'est sûr que pour le
gouvernement legault c'est un boulet
parce que bon la première vague au
québec ça a été une catastrophe et
l'état une piètre état des ch et celle
des qui avaient été laissées par les
gouvernements précédents l'expliquent en
partie
mais c'était le cas aussi en ontario est
proportionnellement il ya eu beaucoup
moins de morts dans leur centre de soins
de longue durée au québec alors c'est
qu'il ya eu des problèmes spécifiques
ici qui sont aussi redevable au
gouvernement actuel et c'est pour ça que
ça prend une vraie enquête publique que
j'ai l'impression que la coroner kamel
bon probablement le recommandé m
il faut aller au fond de sa était en une
une enquête publique pour le pour le
viaduc encore là on a eu de plus de 5000
québécois québécoise mort dans des
conditions du mans atroce si ça ça
mérite une enquête publique concernant
bien seulement
chef david la coronaire qui disent
avaient été des enfants on serait en
train dure dix ans et
elle pose des questions difficiles en
effet à des sous ministres à monsieur
harouna etc on a l'impression qu'à
lâchera pas comme dit josé le morceau et
que les explications qu'on lui fait
sanaa la satisfait pas quelque chose qui
manque là dedans michel je comprends que
cela satisfasse pas on c'est vrai on a
appris à connaître la carrière kamel
mais on commence à connaître le docteur
arruda aussi et c'est sébastien beauvais
france musique qui parlait du
vocabulaire arudyens mais là quand on
dit on avait comme une pensée qui
pourrait y avoir un problème commun
comme une pensée
c'est absolument hallucinant si pour
avoir un problème on dit quels sont les
problèmes qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
pas une pensée et on se rencontre
monsieur monsieur avoue donne nous dit
bah on avait une idée de mode février il
ya eu un comité qui s'est penchée
spécifiquement sur les ch à s'élever au
mois d'avril alors qu'est ce qui s'est
fait entre les deux il ya quelque chose
qui a pas de bon ça on a vu que 1 des
problèmes bon il y avait le problème la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre qu'on
connaissait et qu'on pouvait pas régler
du jour au lendemain mais par exemple
tout le problème de l'équipement ça a
pris une éternité avant que le québec se
décide en commande et la colombie
britannique l'a fait bien avant alors la
guerre mondiale pour l'équipement des
oui effectivement quand le québec ccq
c'est décidé elle battait son plein mais
il des gens qui l'avaient qu'il l'avait
prévu et qui sont passés avant nous
alors non il ya beaucoup de choses à
fouiller là dedans et je suis tout à
fait d'accord depuis toujours d'ailleurs
qu'il n'arrête une enquête publique
s'impose
j'ai comme l'impression que ça va finir
par arriver mais que le gouvernement va
s'organiser pour que disons ça débouche
pas sur grand chose certainement pas
avant la prochaine élection oui hélène
vaut votre vision de 3 de sa
non mais je dis d'ottawa parce que
monsieur trudeau dans ce dossier-là
avait fait miroiter tous d'accord le
code des conditions pour plus de
financement dans les sachets celle
d'hier et il répète souvent parce que ça
a été un exemple de bonne gestion québec
donc
comment vous voyez ouais c'est pas que
parce que monsieur trudeau tout d'un
coup veut imposer des normes comme par
magie sur elles s'appliqueront à on sait
bien que les raisons pour lesquelles ça
fonctionne pas dans les 6 h et celle des
parce qu'il ya un manque de personnel et
cetera et cetera auquel on n'est pas
capable de dire qu'on est pas capable de
résoudre moi je mettrais seulement une
petite un petit bémol par rapport à tout
ce qu'on a entendu c'est intéressant
tout ce processus le mais faut quand
même prendre garde de ne pas
trop juge il passé à la lumière de ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui mais qu'on ne
savait pas nécessairement à l'époque je
trouve quand même intéressant quand les
autorités nous disent oui mais on en
avait un le plan mais il ya certaines
solutions qui faisait partie du plan qui
se sont révélés à être la source du
problème je pense par exemple à
l'interdiction du des aidants naturels
d'avoir accès au chs ld on pensait comme
ça protéger nos personnes âgées parce
qu'on pensait que ces gens là seraient
porteurs du virus finalement ça a été
une source d'un grand problème
évidemment ces gens là ce sont nos
personnes âgées sont retrouvés sans
haine l'idée de ne pas les envoyer à
l'hôpital ou alors de les retourner des
hôpitaux vers les chs des ch et celle
d'e.on penser que parce que ce sera
l'hôpital qui aurait des dizaines de
milliers d'hospitalisations et que ce
serait là le passé moi l'expression le
ground zero finalement c'est plutôt
l'inversé qui est arrivé on l'a envoyé
nos personnes âgées vers l'enfer les
eaux gardez en enfer way
we malaisie jose oui oui mais c'est
parce que c'est ça fait partie des
nombreux morceaux qui manque au puzzle
lorsque monsieur aroud a dit qu' il y
avait une pensée donc ça voulait dire
que oui j'étais au courant puis c'était
d'ailleurs ce qui circulait à travers le
monde et la décision quand même été
prise de vider des lits d'hôpitaux
comment on dit dans les lits avec des
humains qu'on a catapulté dans des ch et
celle des le fils d'une mère qui est
morte comme ça avait dit qu'on avait
envoyé sa mère l'abattoir a
littéralement parce qu'elle y est morte
la commune de 19 dans un siège chez cd
alors que ce serait pas arrivée à
l'hôpital
mais comment on a pu décider ça en même
temps qu'on n'a pas préparé ces milieux
de villas et de soins est là le vrai
problème il est là et on sait très gêné
lorsque lorsque l'histoire sur le siège
chez celles des privés et rennes est
sorti dans la gazette c'est là que tout
à coup tout est apparu il y avait tout
était comme un peu dire et communaux
merton un système et d'un million du
coup beaucoup de problèmes qu'il faut
étudier et moi je ne vois pas comment on
va pouvoir arriver au fond de cette
question aux leurres parce que ça
questionne tout système de santé tout le
réseau complet ça y est on est
rapidement a ajouté la fille qu'il ya un
problème plus profond dans le chcd
l'absence de véritables soins médicaux
resort plusieurs médecins le disent il
ya plein d'hommes de soins qu'on est pas
capable compte qu'on ne donne pas qu'on
ne prendrait pas dans ces milieux l'oeil
qui devrait light est donc quelque chose
de beau qui pré date la pandémie qui
doit être réglée et qui explique le fait
qu'on s'est retrouvé comme soft est
capable de soigner ce biais les chaînes
nécessité que très bien quand on est
toutes les réponses en tout cas michel
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème de
livraison soins dans les sachets celle
des mais là on parle pas de ça on parle
de donner de l'eau au pensionnaire
nourrir de nourrir et d'hydrater l'aja
il ya une sous-ministre adjointe qui est
précisément un responsable des aînés au
ministère qui dit on savait pas qui
était pas et hydratée on savait qu'il ya
pas de personnel mais on sait pas qui
était pas eu des ratés mais c'est pas de
personnel des personnes pour les
hydrater là il ya tout un mystère la
dalle acquis que la simple simplement
dire on manquait de personnel ça
c est parce que même dans livre de notre
collègue castonguay je lui ai dit à ceux
à ce panel il ya plusieurs mois cette
partie là on n'a pas toutes les réponses
pas vrai parce que quand vous préparez
les hôpitaux qu'est ce qu'on faisait au
même moment la sous-ministre personnes
âgées pour lui sachent à celle des
autres bref on aura fait mais oui j'ose
louis mais rappelons que c'était une
crise sanitaire avait une cellule de
crise qui existent toujours au sommet de
tout donc c'est vrai mais je pense qu'il
faut savoir c'est quelle sont les
décisions qui ont été prises par cette
cellule de crise là et qui sont ensuite
descendus dans l'appareil peut-être que
le trio sat et marguerite blais lionel
carmant madame et canale pas peut-être
que ça fonctionnait pas tout à fait
comme ça et peut-être que une partie
d'une grande partie de l'explication et
dans la cellule de crise hélène est ce
que le leadership o'toole et combien il
est contesté par une sénatrice
conservatrice qui a fait un petit vidéo
mais est ce que c'est oui c'est sérieux
dans son cas elle mais est-ce sérieux
sur le dans un sur le large spectre on
va on va la prendre au cours d'épreuves
au cours des prochains jours mais ce
qu'on nous dit c'est que c'est une heure
une
organiste et bien organisé on passera
plusieurs sorties au cours des trois
voire six prochains mois donc on veut
comme pilonné comme seul ébranlé le
leadership de monsieur o toole en même
temps faut quand même prendre un autre
que ya plusieurs gros noms qui sont
sortis à la défense de monsieur otto je
pense par exemple à michel même peau je
pense aussi à melissa lantsman que
travailler à l'époque de monsieur harper
et qui dit
tout le monde mais c'est vrai que ça
fait extrêmement mal et rappelez vous
monsieur chieusse avait pris du temps à
aussi avant qu'on lui montre la porte
quelque part en décembre après
l'élection donc il n'est pas encore
sorti du bois monsieur autour on monte
la porte terminer même chez les jeunes
zone euro le temps d'en reparler si
c'est le supplice de la goutte que vous
nous annoncez on aura le temps d'en
reparler merci beaucoup mais je pense
est important de donner deux dans les
sachets celle évidemment merci beaucoup
au revoir en soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit